what's the difference between
a state-of-the-art human such as you and
i well i don't know if we qualify as
stated that our humans but
a state-of-the-art human and a
state-of-the-art robot
that's a very interesting question
capability is
it's kind of a i think it's a very
tricky thing to
to to understand because there are some
things that are difficult that we
wouldn't think are difficult and some
things that are easy that we wouldn't
think are easy um and there's also a
really big gap between
capabilities of robots in terms of
hardware and their physical capability
and capabilities of
robots in terms of what they can do
autonomously there is a little video
that
i think robotics researchers really like
to show a special robotics learning
researchers like myself
from 2004 from stanford which
demonstrates a prototype robot called
the pr1
and the pr1 was a robot that was
designed as a home assistance robot and
there's this beautiful video showing the
pr one
uh tidying up a living room putting away
toys
and at the end bringing a a beer to the
person sitting on the couch
which looks really amazing and then the
punch line is that this
robot is entirely controlled by a person
yes so you can
so that in some ways the gap between a
state-of-the-art human state-of-the-art
robot
if the robot has a human brain is
actually not that large
now obviously like human bodies are
sophisticated and very robust and
resilient in many ways
but on the whole if we're willing to
like spend a bit of money and do a bit
of engineering
we can kind of close the hardware gap
almost
but the intelligence gap that one is
very wide and when you say hardware you
you're referring to the physical sort of
the actuators the actual body of the
robot as opposed to the hardware
on which the cognition the nervous the
hardware of the nervous system yes
exactly i'm referring to the the body
rather than the mind
so so that means that the kind of the
work is cut out for us like we
while we can still make the body better
we kind of know that the big bottleneck
right now is really the mind
and how big is that gap how big is the
how big is the difference in your in
your sense of ability to learn a bit
ability to reason ability to perceive
the world between
humans and our best robots
the gap is very large and the gap
becomes
larger the more unexpected events can
happen in the world
so essentially the spectrum along which
you can measure
uh the the the size of that gap is the
spectrum of how open the world is if you
control everything in the world very
tightly if you put the robot
in like a factory and you tell it where
everything is and you rigidly program
its motion
then it can do things you know one might
even say in a superhuman way it can move
faster it's stronger it can lift up a
car and things like that
but as soon as anything starts to vary
in the environment
now it'll trip up and if many many
things vary like they would like in your
kitchen for example
then things are pretty much like wide
open
now again we're going to stick a bit on
the philosophical questions but
how much on the human side of the
cognitive abilities in your sense
is nature versus nurture so so how much
of it
is a product of
evolution and how much of it is
something we learned from sort of
scratch
yeah well from the day we're born i'm
going to read into your question as
asking about
the implications of this for ai
i'm not a biologist i can't really like
speak authoritatively so
into lingard if if it's so if it's all
about learning
then there's more hope for ai yeah so
the way that i look at this is that
um you know well first of course biology
is very messy
and it's if you ask the question how
does a person do something or has a
person's mind do something
you come up with a bunch of hypotheses
and oftentimes you can find support for
many different
often conflicting hypotheses um one way
that we can approach
the question of of what the implications
of this for a
air is we can think about what's
sufficient so
you know maybe a person is from birth
very very good at some things like for
example recognizing faces there's a very
strong evolutionary pressure to do that
if you can recognize
your mother's face then you're more
likely to survive and
therefore people are good at this but we
can also ask like what's what's the
minimum sufficient thing
right and one of the ways that we can
study the minimal sufficient thing is we
could
for example see what people do in
unusual situations if you present them
with things that evolution couldn't have
prepared them for
you know our daily lives actually do
this to us all the time we we didn't
evolve to deal with
you know automobiles and space flight
and whatever
um so they're all these situations that
we can find ourselves in uh
and we do very well there like i can
give you a joystick to control a robotic
arm
uh which you've never used before and
you might be pretty bad for the first
couple of seconds but if i tell you like
your life depends on using this robotic
arm to like
open this door you'll probably manage it
even though you've never seen this
device before you
you've never used the joystick
controllers and you'll kind of muddle
through it
and that's not your evolve natural
ability that's your
your flexibility or your adaptability
and that's exactly where our current
robotic systems really kind of fall flat
but i wonder how much general
almost what we think of as common sense
pre-trained models underneath all that
so that ability to adapt to a joystick
is requires you to have a kind of
you know i'm human so it's hard for me
to introspect all the knowledge i have
about the world but it seems like there
might be an iceberg underneath of the
amount of knowledge
we actually bring to the table that's
kind of the open question i think
there's absolutely
there's absolutely an iceberg of
knowledge that we bring to the table but
i think it's very likely that iceberg of
knowledge is actually built up over our
lifetimes
because we have you know we have a lot
of prior experience to draw on
uh and it kind of makes sense that the
right way for us to
you know to optimize uh our our
efficiency our evolutionary fitness and
so on
is to utilize uh all that experience to
build up the best iceberg we can get
and that's actually one you know while
that sounds an awful lot like what
machine learning actually does
i think that for modern machine learning
it's actually a really big challenge to
take this
unstructured massive experience and
distill out
something that looks like a common sense
understanding of the world
and perhaps part of that isn't it's not
because something about machine learning
itself is
is broken or hard but because we've been
a little too rigid
in subscribing to a very supervised very
rigid notion of learning
you know kind of the input output x's go
to y sort of model
and maybe what we really need to uh to
do is to
view the world more as like a massive
experience that is not necessarily
providing any original supervision but
sort of providing many many instances of
things that could be
and then you take that and you distill
it into some sort of common sense
understanding
i see well you're you're painting an
optimistic beautiful picture
especially from the robotics
perspectives because that means we just
need to invest and build better learning
algorithms
figure out how we can get access to more
and more data
for those learning algorithms to extract
signal from and then
accumulate that iceberg of knowledge
it's a beautiful picture
it's a hopeful one i think it's
potentially a little bit more than
just that um and this is this is where
we perhaps reach the
limits of our current understanding but
one thing that i think that
the research community hasn't really
resolved in a satisfactory way is
uh how much it matters where that
experience comes from like
you know do you just like download
everything on the internet and cram it
into
essentially the 21st century analog of
the
giant language model and and see what
happens or
does it actually matter whether your
machine physically experiences the world
or
in the sense that it actually attempts
things observes the outcome of its
actions and
kind of augments experience that way
that it chooses which parts of the world
it gets to interact with and observe and
learn from
right it may be that the world is so
complex that uh
simply obtaining a large mass of sort of
iid samples of the world
is is a very difficult way to go but uh
if you are actually interacting with the
world and essentially performing the
sort of hard negative mining
by attempting what you think might work
observing the
sometimes happy and sometimes sad
outcomes of that and
augmenting your understanding using that
experience and you're just doing this
continually for many years
maybe that sort of data in some sense is
actually much more favorable to
obtaining a common sense understanding
one reason we might think that this is
true is that
um you know the what we associate with
common sense or lack of common sense
is often characterized by the ability to
uh reason about
kind of counter factual questions like
you know if i were to
uh here i'm this bottle of water is
sitting on the table everything is fine
if i knock it over
uh which i'm not going to do but if i
were to do that what would happen
and i know that nothing good would
happen from that but if i have a bad
understanding of the world
i might think that that's a good way for
me to like you know gain more utility
uh if i actually go about the my
daily life doing the things that my
current understanding of the world
suggests will give me high utility
in some ways i'll get exactly the the
right uh
supervision to tell me not to do those
bad things and to keep doing the good
things
so there's a spectrum between iid
random walk through the space of data
and then there's and
what we humans do well i don't even know
if we do it
optimal but that might be beyond what so
this open question that you raised where
do you think
systems intelligence systems that would
be able to
deal with this world fall can we do
pretty well by reading all of wikipedia
sort of randomly sampling it like
language models do
or do we have to be exceptionally
selective and intelligent about
which aspects of the world we track with
so i think this is first an open
scientific problem and i don't have like
a clear answer but i can speculate a
little bit
and what i would speculate is that you
don't need to be
super super careful i think it's less
about like
being careful to avoid the useless stuff
and more about making sure that you hit
on the really important stuff
so perhaps it's okay if you spend part
of your day
just you know guided by your curiosity
visiting interesting regions of the
of your state space but it's important
for you to
you know every once in a while make sure
that you really try out
the uh solutions that your current model
of the world suggests might be effective
and observe whether those solutions are
working as you expect or not
and perhaps uh some of that is really
essential to have
kind of a perpetual improvement loop
this perpetual improvement loop is
really like
that's really the key the key that's
going to potentially distinguish
the best current methods from the best
methods of tomorrow in a sense
you